United pick better people to work for
you
please
Marlon Wayans calling out United
Airlines
I don't know what kind of corporate
culture there is
your customers are always right well
Kansas City I'm going to miss my shows
tonight because of a gate agent at uh
United Airlines
the comedian was on route from Denver to
Kansas City for a couple of stand-up
shows which he ended up missing I know
how to make you laugh
now I want to make you think to leave
people with something greater than just
a smile and in a video shared to
Instagram Marlon broke down the incident
claiming he was asked to consolidate his
luggage to abide by the airlines to bag
policy this man was wrong and I was
targeted
period
and then
I get corporate called me and they
defend
well you know there is a two bag policy
right and so I took my three bags that
turned into two
right but then he got a text that
there's no more room on the plane oh is
that so really so then why did all those
people before me and all these people
after me have two bags and three bags
interesting according to reports Marlon
was given a citation over the matter
where he was allegedly frustrated that
he had to check his bag adding that he
then slammed his ticket on the counter
and proceeded to board a gate agent
reportedly called security who escorted
him off the plane following the incident
Marlin asked the airline for
compensation since he claims they're the
reason he didn't make it to his gigs
United pick better people to work for
you
please
a statement to ET United Airlines media
relations confirmed a customer who was
told to gate check his bag pushed past
an employee to board the plane and
ultimately did not fly with the airline
to his destination but Marlon made it
out to Denver sharing this pig and
writing fly were you respected protected
and loved
questions